que vient chercher volodières zenenski à
Bruxelles alors c'est vrai que Vladimir
Zelinski il craint à l'approche de la
date anniversaire du 24 février donc un
an d'invasion du flan est de son pays
une offensive russe et il voudrait il
attend évidemment d'abord des Européens
des armes et il l'attend tellement des
armes qu'il est d'ailleurs il a
d'ailleurs rendu visite aux États-Unis
puis même à la Grande-Bretagne hier ce
qui vexe un peu les Européens parce que
si on regarde les chiffres en fait
les Européens n'ont pas vraiment à
rougir ils ont 3,5 milliards d'euros
dans une facilité pour la paix pour les
armes et en fait si on compte aussi la
contribution des États membres 10
milliards d'euros sont consacrés à ce
chapitre c'est-à-dire 40% de l'aide
américaine ce qui est non négligeable
mais par contre si on regarde le le
Global finalement de leur aide en
incluant effectivement leur
reconstruction au jour le jour du réseau
électrique le raid pour les écoles leur
aide également pour les 5 millions de
réfugiés qui sont sur notre sol et bien
on est aux alentours de 60 milliards
côté européens très largement devant les
Américains et donc la diplomatie du parc
portefeuille a fonctionné à plein c'est
vrai que la semaine dernière il y avait
collège des commissaires où j'étais
présente au côté du lavanderleyen et
Charles Michel aussi pour un sommet à
Kiev sur le sol ukrainien tout le monde
se bouscule pour être un peu sur la
photo en compagnie de volodiainski à
juste titre parce que toutes ces
institutions aident à diverses parts du
finalement du
de l'aide à l'Ukraine mais aujourd'hui
il va donc prononcer un grand discours
devant la plénière du Parlement européen
où il y a quand même 30% de réceptiques
qui parfois est épousent plutôt les
thèses russes devant le Conseil européen
des 27 il va se présenter aussi où il y
a certains chefs d'État qui n'aiment pas
vraiment typiquement Victor Hormann pour
la Hongrie qui qui a beaucoup vous
freiner des quatre fers pour ce qu'il
s'agissait d'aider l'Ukraine et
continuer à avoir des relations
privilégiées avec Moscou le l'Union
européenne a offert quelque chose que
les que le que finalement les États-Unis
ne pourront jamais offrir une
perspective d'adhésion au club européen
à l'Ukraine justement le commentaire
peut-être du chancelier allemand la sole
hier c'est un signe fort que le
président
ukrainien participe personnellement à
cette première réunion de l'année des
chefs d'État et gouvernement de de lieu
font remonter un an en arrière c'était
le début le début du conflit avec les
Russes il participait par
visioconférence depuis la fin un sacré
chemin en direction d'une adhésion
faut dire la vérité express du tout les
temps on n'a jamais vu en quelques mois
ficelé une candidature qui aboutit au
mois de juin avec la perspective du côté
ukrainien on dit pourquoi pas dans deux
ans alors dans deux ans c'est il
faudrait savoir quand est-ce qu'on sort
de la guerre bien sûr le Haut
représentant nous a dit deux trois ans
aussi mais ça ça correspond à la
décision express de un pays comme la
slova problématique l'Ukraine est très
problématique du point de vue de la
corruption on a bien vu que
volodimeersky avant l'arrivée des
Européens a dû faire un peu le ménage et
notamment comment ça procéder à des
remaniements puisque beaucoup de ces
ministres sont touchés par des histoires
de corruption et de détournement de
fonds publics ce que les Européens vont
mettre un peu sur la table aujourd'hui
c'est comment on
intensifie encore l'aide par exemple la
Pologne et les pays baltes font pression
sur les responsables de l'Union
européenne pour qu'ils utilisent les
avoir gelées russes pour aider à la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine il y a 300
il y a 300 milliards de dollars d'avoir
gelé donc 33 milliards sur le sol
européen et ça et on voudrait pouvoir le
transférer aux Ukrainiens mais
juridiquement on ne sait pas si c'est
tout à fait viable la Commission et le
G7 est en train de d'étudier la question
effectivement ce qu'il y a d'important à
savoir c'est que c'est important aussi
pour les Européens de recevoir sur le
sol volody mirzelinski parce qu'ils ont
aussi un message à adresser à leur
propre concitoyens qui sont gravement
touchés par la crise énergétique
qui ont parfois tendance à générer des
mouvements sociaux et là il faut pouvoir
s'afficher avec ce leader pour dire pour
développer ce narratif du Ukraine qui
est victime de l'agression russe et
qu'il faut aider à tout prix Caroline
nous restait évidemment